[Musique]
ambiance musicale au château du moulin
de beauséjour à saint-jean de brainiac
près de bordeaux c'est dans ce vignoble
de renom qu'on fait la réunion une
journée placée sous le signe de la bonne
humeur et du partage j'avais envie tant
qu'ambassadeur d'honneur de l'île de la
réunion de mettre en avant les charmes
de la réunion à travers sa sa culture
son folklore sa gastronomie également
pendant la journée le public pourra se
restaurer donc il y à des traiteurs
réunionnais qui vont proposer des des
plats cuisinés et le public va pouvoir
écouter de la musique tout au long de la
journée
on a travaillé de concert avec pas mal
de deux partenaires notamment le conseil
général et plus particulièrement sa
présidente nassimah dindar qui lorsque
je lui ai parlé de ce projet m'a tout de
suite encouragé à rien lâché et a
héliporté jusqu'à son terme le
département qui proposait de retrouver
des saveurs de la réunion de les
découvrir sur son stand on arrive les
mains vides et on repart les bras
chargés de fruits et de soleil
moi je suis venu à peu retrouvé mais ça
mes racines un peu que c'est vraiment la
musique l'ambiance les couleurs aussi
des fruits sont fraîches que je retrouve
des ananas et des fruits de la passion
un petit pont fait toujours plaisir
j'ai un frère qui était à la réunion
j'ai jamais eu l'occasion d'y aller j'ai
hâte d'y aller oui je vais apprendre un
peu parce que c'est le pays de la
réunion je suis une fan de la réunion
jir revient régulièrement
j'adore la réunion j'aime dans les
réunionnais
ils m'ont appris beaucoup de choses je
vous félicite les réunionnais et je vais
repartir encore une fois
l'opération séduction est une réussite
près de 500 personnes se sont déplacées
dans le domaine de beauséjour vivre la
réunion sans prendre l'avion c'est donc
possible
voilà une belle réussite et c'est là non
qui gagne là qui est présenté la réunion
qui est fière de ses valeurs
fier de ses produits qui est présente et
c'est tant mieux
là vous nous montrez bien capable par de
présence avec nos produits notre culture
de pouvoir nous vendre au sens propre du
terme
ailleurs il est en terre bordelaise donc
bravo à lui des cadres à la casse bravo
la maison de la réunion à paris notre
boutique qui a connu un franc lviv
succès un point tel que pratiquement
tout le stock est parti donc c'est une
bonne nouvelle
une preuve que la réunion c'est faire
rayonner ses savoir faire
là
[Musique]